i think we can get started
so welcome to the first open lecture of
the semester
i am very pleased and honored to
introduce to you professor mark feldman
from stanford university
professor feldman has
obtained his phd in mathematics in 1969
from stanford under the
supervision of a renowned mathematician
sam carlin
and since 1971
professor feldman has been on the
faculty in the department of biological
sciences
also at stanford
so the title of his phd thesis was some
topics in
theoretical population genetics
and following that general theme i think
one could try to summarize his subject
subsequent career as many topics in
population genetics
indeed he has published over 500
articles in the field and has trained
numerous numerous students and postdocs
many of whom have moved on to become
leaders in the field themselves
and in recognition of his important
contributions
he has received many hours and honors
too many to list now but maybe just to
name a few
they include
guggenheim fellowship then david price
elected memberships in
american academy of arts and sciences
national academy of sciences and
american philosophical society
among the many things that he has done
uh professor feldman is well known for
originating the mathematical theory of
cultural evolution and today he will
tell us about next generation cultural
evolution cultural niche construction
and multi-dimensionality
let's give it a long welcome
thanks thank you
thanks very much jun and thank you to
the simon's institute for
their
foresight in
developing this interdisciplinary
program this year
it
looks very exciting
i was supposed to be here last week but
i got caught up with one of the
viruses that's going around and couldn't
make it for the week but
um i'm looking forward to interacting
with all of the different people from
computer science and physics and biology
that
are inhabiting
the simons institute
not knowing
to whom i would be speaking today
i tried to
think of different
problems that
somebody who's interested in genetics
might
think about from the point of view
of
somebody who's interested in the
evolution of culture
and
as the subject has matured since uh
kawali schwarz and i
first began this work in the early 70s
there hasn't been a great deal of work
to make it as complex as the changes
have happened in genetics
and one of the things that the last few
years
has occupied my group has been to try to
see whether we can
address some of the criticisms that
anthropologists originally made
of the theory that we developed
that it didn't take enough of culture
into account
and in fact that you couldn't take
culture into account and make it into
something you could study quantitatively
um so i i hope that we're
trying we're gradually making progress
in extending its complexity
and its dimensionality
and also incorporating some of the ideas
that my colleague kevin leyland john
idling smee
and i developed in our work on niche
construction
which i'll explain as we go along
so
i don't think darwin was a great fan of
cultural evolution in fact he said that
he hasn't met any evidence in support of
the transmission of superstitious
customs or senseless habits
which today we would regard as quite
erroneous
that there seems to be all around us
plenty of evidence to that effect
on the other hand if you ask for the
definition of the process of adaptation
you get two quite conflicting views
about it
one of them is the one which is mostly
accepted by ecologists
that
organisms
try and solve problems that are posed by
the environment
and on the other hand
lewinton
doesn't buy that
and
he invented the term construction
by saying that they don't adapt to their
environments they construct them out of
bits and pieces of the external world
and that was what actually led
my colleagues and i to
use the term this construction
when we began this subject in the early
90s
and in fact we defined it with a rather
complex definition
but
the idea of it was that some
organisms actively or inactively change
the environment that other organisms
operate in even organisms of their own
species
to the extent that they can change the
selective forces that act on those
organisms in their own or other species
and the result of that is a change in
the formalism that you would put into a
population genetics model
that would be describing the evolution
of organisms subject to niche
construction
and in fact what we showed in our
original work
uh in the book you can see some of the
examples
is that the dynamics become extremely
complicated and you can have cycling
and all sorts of things that are more
commonly associated with uh theoretical
ecology than with theoretical population
genetics
um
my post doc yasuo ihara who's now
professor at tokyo university
had the idea that if you could think of
organisms altering the environments of
other organisms that they're in contact
with or that are going to be there after
the former organisms have departed we
could think of the same thing in
anthropological terms
by thinking of
cultural traits that influenced the
evolution of other cultural traits or
other biological traits
and in that way you could address what
anthropologists and
some psychologists call context
dependence
and the cultural context in which
the evolution of some
cultural phenomena occurs
could be very important in changing the
way the evolution
proceeds
and i've got
an example that shows how this might
happen
uh it's a very
i think a very strange example of this
kind but there's no doubt that it fits
that kind of definition
and it concerns data that
my colleague melissa brown and i worked
on from taiwan
the advantage of the data are is that
the japanese
occupiers of taiwan from 1895 to 1945
were absolutely meticulous in the
demography of
taiwan
so every birth death marriage
every
a bit of income that came in
who lived in which household is
documented in excruciating detail
whether the people were aboriginal
and there were
two large groups of aboriginal people in
taiwan or
chinese
mainlanders
the mainlanders
that we today associate with the term
mostly came after 49
but there were a group of
people who came much earlier um these
people the hack are generally well known
primarily because of their restaurants
in
famous cities but the hot glow people
were also there and they came hundreds
of years ago
but the indigenous people the aborigines
there was two main groups the mountains
and the plains groups and the plains
groups were involved in farming the
mountain groups were not
but those people
genetically are much more closely
related to melanesian than they are to
east asians
and many of the customs they have
for example
tattooing moustaches on the women is a
custom that you see in many parts of
melanesia and even among the ainu in
japan
presumably to make the women uh less
attractive to invading
uh marauders
now the han people from the very
beginning bound the feet of the women
and as girls and you can see
how excruciating that must have been
there are museums in china where they
you can see these shoes which are this
big where they've tied
the feet of the girls so the girls could
not move
out of the household and one of the
reasons maybe
another study that is melissa is working
on with other people has to do with
their value as weavers and spinners
of uh textiles that they did this
from the home never having left the home
during their whole life
but
in 1915
the japanese outlawed foot binding
and
the things that happened can be picked
up in the census data in the demographic
data
almost immediately
and what you see is not only a change in
religious and burial practices but a big
change in marriage practices
so
what happened to the marriage customs
were the han people
regarded the aboriginals as barbarians
because they did not bind the feet of
the women
and that they thought gave the women so
much autonomy that they would never
serve as good wives
so
most
marriages
the overwhelming majority of marriages
that the han took place took
part in were what are called very local
marriages
that is the man stayed with where he was
and the woman moved in
the aborigines didn't care too much
about that they had quite a bit of you
sorry local marriage yoxura local
marriage is the custom where a man moves
in to live with the girl's family on the
mainland in china that is very rare in
the rural districts you very rarely see
that happen
and that's part of the
ongoing problem of uh the sex ratio bias
and who look who is supposed to look
after the elderly when they get old
what happened
after
the foot binding
ban
you can see here this is the fraction of
your local marriages among the
aborigines
and you can see that it's quite high it
gets as high in that one village there
one that one set of aborigines as high
as 35 percent of the marriages where you
cure a local this is the fraction of
your local marriages
and by 1945 it's below five percent
and it's it goes down uh radically
um
among the harm there were this one
village that had 25
which dropped down to
under 5 by 1945.
so that act of
making foot binding
illegal
um and thereby forcing the women into
the fields and the the motivation behind
the japanese uh change of that law
had to do with their aim of increasing
food production
and increasing
the industrial production of taiwan to
do that they would have to build roads
and buildings so the men would have to
get away from the fields and that would
leave nobody to work the fields so the
women had to get out of the house to
work the fields
and the japanese
exploited the food that was being
produced by taiwan almost all of it was
exported to japan
so
the consequences of the foot binding
ban
which is an institution whose
in whose context all these other things
must have occurred
not only led to this radical change in
marriage customs
but
within about 10 years the spirit medium
who up until that time had always been a
woman in this aboriginal culture
no longer became a woman even though in
interviews with people
um there's general agreement that the
spirit spiritual leader we would call it
the shaman should still be a woman
but there was no way that if a woman got
married
that her sister's in law would look
after any children which made it
impossible for such a thing to happen
for a woman to continue to be a shaman
in addition you saw uh changing burial
practices that the
han people kept their grave sites
incredibly clean swept them and all that
sort of thing you didn't that that
suddenly took over in the aboriginal
community too and as well these
ornaments which were not part of
aboriginal culture within 10 years
became completely normal in the
aboriginal culture
so
this abandonment foot binding had this
chain
salutary effect on other cultural
aspects
so i would say that that's a good
example of foot binding forming a
cultural niche in which the other things
happened and the removal of it exploded
the
possibilities for other cultural things
to happen
now
how how might you go about trying to
model this kind of thing well here is
the first primitive model
of expanding the dimensionality of the
number of cultural traits that you look
at at once into three in fact
and
the three that we chose to look at
are a defining trait and this is what we
would call the focal trait the one
you're really interested in
and another culturally transmitted trait
which affects the selection that might
go on this trade and the selection being
darwinian type selection so you can
think of it either as viability or
fecundity or fertility
but in addition there's been a lot of
work in the last five to ten years
on social homophobially
i'm awfully being in
if you're a geneticist you might have
previously thought about it as
assortative mating
but it's also a sortative meeting
so it's a question of who you associate
with
i will treat it here uh in this context
as assortative mating
but we've done a great deal of work as
well
on treating it as a sortative meeting
after the mating has occurred and
children have matured
the general term for that these days is
homophily
so one can think of cultural
transmission parameters which operate on
the trade itself
on the process that leads to selection
and on the process that decides whether
you will or will not
mate assortatively
that's also culturally transmitted for
example the preference to make with
somebody who's of the same religion as
you are is certainly not a biological
trait it's a culturally transmitted
trait
and the consequences of that culturally
transmitted trait
could be many other culturally
transmitted traits such as whether you
might
agree to use contraception or fertility
control
if you were to study both of those
together you have two different cultural
traits and they may have what a
biologist would call epistasis or
interaction between them
and therefore you would have to include
that if you were going to make a
dynamical model out of this
so we did that with
selection parameters that depended only
on the difference between big s and
little s
and
the
assortative mating parameters that only
depended on whether you had a big m or a
little m
and
this is an example of what happens with
homophily where you uh this
we chose this guy here the first part of
the mating team to make the choice and
when that one makes the choice it's
choosing only among those that are
having the same
t big t or little t so the choice is
made
by you're having a big m or a little m
but on the basis of whether you're a big
t or a little t that's the trait on
which you're sorting
and this this is the part of the
dynamics of course this is just one
example of the dynamics is
to write it down you would have to have
a couple of pages to write down the full
dynamical system
here's an example of the outcome of
iterating that and this was done
numerically because you have very little
chance of
resolving this
eight-dimensional dynamical system
mathematically you can prove certain
things around the boundaries of the
simplex that this deterministic eight
dimensional system is operating in
but you're unlikely to be able to say
much about the interior
now this is an example of what's
happening on one four-dimensional
boundary
where this big s is fixed so
there is no little s in the system
and
this it looks like almost a perfect
cycle
and it isn't it's a cycle
but if we're iterating this at the level
of 10 to the minus 16 which we were
a lot of these points are not exactly at
that 10 to the minus 16 being similar
some
many times when we see this happening
there are 10 to the minus 5 apart
so it looks like a cycle when you draw
it and it's very difficult to know
what it is whether it's actually a real
cycle or not
and it's not part of a bifurcating
scheme because we don't see any fixed
point that changes into that when you
change the parameter so it's not a
standard kind of a cycle but it happens
quite frequently and you can see that it
looks very very cyclic
but in addition
you have really interesting dynamics
other dynamics here is a case
where on this boundary of this simplex
you have two possibilities you've got
this point here which is a fixed point
and all of the starting conditions in
the simplex that have red arrows end up
there
but if you start where these blue arrows
are then you go into this cycle
so it's a very strange thing that i've
never seen in a genetics model
this is an example the same example of
what happened when you actually went
into that fixed point that is uh
has
the the boundary polymorphism so you
have here a stable polymorphism of all
eight and that one
looks like this here is the the pink
thing here has the polymorphism and the
other thing is a fixed point which is
just a monomorphism
so depending on where you start from you
either got a complete polymorphism or a
fixed monomorphism that sort of thing we
have seen in population genetics quite a
lot
but this one
did not have a cycle in it
and the others did so
you can
perturb the parameters slightly and move
from having stable fixed points to
stable
what appears to be stable cycles or
most of the time you don't get any of
that you just get fixations of one of
these corners
now
one of the things that happens regularly
in these models of uh cultural
transmission and if i go back and show
you this
set of numbers here
if this was a one a half a half and zero
that would be symptomatic of pure
genetics
and every time you use only pure
genetics in the transmission system you
never get any polymorphisms
no matter whether you put recombination
between these different traits or not
you never get polymorphisms and that's a
bit of a mystery as to why it is
that mendel's rule applying to these of
course haploid systems
doesn't allow you to get polymorphism
whereas with cultural transmission
you can
the sensitivity of the outcome of a
dynamical system with cultural
transmission is actually quite striking
this is an example where i have three
traits and for wants of better
symbolisms we call them plus minus and
star
and they have frequencies u v and w
and i write down a mating table between
the m the female and the male or the
father and the mother depending on how
you want to uh call them and there are
these mating types here they're
symmetric the
heterogamic matings are
considered to be equivalent
and this is the cultural transmission
parameters this is the probability that
a mating of plus by plus gives you a
minus it's 0.1
and similarly two stars when they mate
give you 0.9 of getting a star
this dynamic has one fixed point
and it's exactly equal to castle's law
what sewell wright called castle's law
instead of the hardy-weinberg law
um he always attributed the
hardy-weinberg law to castle
but castle did it with p equals a half
and that's what you would end up with um
at p equals a half but now
if you change these parameters the
transmission parameters by less than
five percent by a tiny amount
then you end up with a model where you
have something that doesn't look at all
genetic where all the three frequencies
are exactly equal
and that would be a lot of people would
see this in their data and say oh that's
very looks very symptomatic of genetics
and of course it's symptomatic of this
kind of cultural transmission which is
close to mendelian but not very far from
this one which is giving you this
weird outcome
of equal frequencies
now what we have just been discussing
is all about transmission
and not saying whether the transmission
is due to teaching or learning
now many anthropologists have for years
denied that active teaching occurs in
hunter-gatherer tribes
and the one exception is barry hewlett
and he worked closely has worked closely
with luca cavalli schweitzer in his
studies of pygmies and they have some
very famous papers
on
the vertical cultural transmission of
traits in the pygmies in central african
republic
and
he discovered
with his 35 years of working with the
forest pygmies
that pedagogy and other forms of
teaching exist as early as 12 months of
age
but were relatively infrequent by
comparison to other processes of social
learning
now in his last papers what he's
discovered is the difference between how
much of this teaching goes on in the
hunter-gatherer people
and in the farming people that live
right next part next door to them and
for whom they work
and that a lot of the transmission of
characters in the pygmies who are
actually working for the
farmers
is vertical cultural transmission but it
happens very early
and at the among the farmers there's
almost no vertical cultural transmission
because the parents are out in the
fields leaving the children
with older brothers and sisters and the
older brothers and sisters are sometimes
as old as three and four
and their job is to look after the
younger ones
so in his recent papers barry has
discovered this notion that vertical
cultural teaching occurs in
hunter-gatherers so
um together with
my colleague kenichi aoki of
now he's at major university and spent
his career mainly at tokyo university
and
former postdoc joe wakano who's now also
at major university we decided to look
at the consequences of
teaching
and we will call it altruistic teaching
because the idea behind it is it costs
the teacher something in terms of time
or energy that could otherwise be
fruitfully used for product production
of something
and we call that altruistic teaching now
you can argue with the term altruistic
but
we call it that because
commonly in the biological literature if
it costs you something to do it that is
going to benefit another person whether
it is your child or an unrelated
individual it is given the name altruism
and the first model that i'm going to
show
is a model of
asexual transmission
and there's going to be a gene
which t which is a dichotomy between
teaching and not teaching
and there's going to be a trait which is
the trait which you learn which is
transmitted
and we'll call it bar and not bar
and the teachers can transmit that at
that rate alpha and the non-teachers
transmitted at a lower rate
and the difference between the bar and
the knot bar is where the fitness is
happening
so what's going on here
is this is almost like a two locus trait
except it's not one is a gene and one is
a culturally transmitted trait
and
there are four
phenogenotypes and we can write them as
with the gene and the bar or not bar on
top
and then we can ask
what happens to the evolution of those
frequencies of these
uh variables
now after vertical transmission
the cost to the
teacher
is this delta
and these are the transmission rates so
this is after vertical transmission
at the cost of teaching
then one postulates that there is a
neural structure that has to be
developed in the child before the child
can learn and that has a cost gamma but
when it learns it there's an advantage a
gain in fitness to that child which is s
so you have to
con found those two combine those two to
end up with a recursion
whose normalizer is this quantity here
but because of this linear nature
and
this linear nature
the whole dynamic is linear fractional
so it's a very easy analysis
and one can uh just give the
uh
answers in terms of the eigenvalues of
this triangular matrix here and it'll
tell you
where
the system is going to end up
and you can show either you end up
without any teachers and without any bar
phenotype
or you end up with no teachers
but both of the phenotypes or only
teachers and both of the phenotypes so
they're the only possibilities that can
happen
and
the nice thing about working with
haploids that don't mate with one
another is that this dynamic is
absolutely complete you don't have to
worry about
cycles or anything
so this
linear fractional is characteristic of
asexual transmission
now if you put in the possibility that
there can be mating between these
uh two different pheno genotype sets
and these are the transmission
parameters within each of these matings
and we then make a simplifying
assumption on the relationships between
the transmission parameters if you have
two parents
with a bar
or one parent with a bar so we make this
one equal to twice that
and similar transmission
assumptions
the very special idea here
just to make the transmission additive
you end up with the following class of
dynamics now the upper pictures
are going to be
the relationship between alpha and beta
and in here it tells you what kind of
fixed points are possible
so to remind you of the coloring
there's the coloring here
so if you end up in a purple place
then you don't have any teachers and no
bar
if you end up in a blue pace you have
no teachers but you have
bar and not bar and if you end up with
light green
you only have teachers
but then there are areas of overlap
where
in grey
you can have both as possibilities or in
dark green you can have both as
possibilities
so that's why
we decided to use this color
representation
as the
description of the dynamics
i'm going the wrong way
let's get back to the picture
so
this is the case of sex ma of mating and
this is the case of the linear
fractional transformation and you can
see that there is no overlap of any of
the possible outcomes
here is an
overlap of the outcome
where you can have both complete absence
of both teaching and
the the phenotypic polymorphism and you
can have fixation
on teachers
you this is only possible in the se in
the case with mating where you actually
have a mating going on you can't have it
in the asexual transmission
now
we change the parameters slightly
this is a parameter one parameter change
and a new thing happens we have a white
strip here
which only happens when you have sexual
reproduction
and that's a polymorphism where you have
all four types present you still have
the other things going on but in here
you have all four types present
there's a tiny little thing there that's
very difficult to see
where there's an overlap
and in this case you actually do see the
dark green
in that place you've got
a situation of bistability but by
stability on two edges where either the
teachers are fixed then you've got both
phenotypes or the non-teachers are fixed
and you've got both phenotypes and here
is where you have a full polymorphism
so this is a very limited parameter set
that we're dealing with yet you have
really interesting dynamics
you always get this kind of
bi-stability in the gray there never
in this
case where you don't have
sexual reproduction
and this is a very large area of
polymorphism
so the
take-home message from this is that if
you put in sexual reproduction with
vertical cultural transmission
the possibilities for polymorphism
for multi-stability by stability in this
four-dimensional case become quite large
and if you only have
asexual transmission then there's
qualitatively not much dependence on the
parameters
you just have these three areas
now the last thing i want to talk about
is a finite population example and this
is an example that will
resonate with people who are doing
genomics
because it's based on the infinitely
many sites model
of population genetics
in one of their most well-known papers
these lysate and garlic
discuss the possible rates of
transmission
in terms of the modes of transmission
these were taken from the book i did
with luca cavalli schwarzer
and their
uh
conclusion as to
who the transmitter would be
who the learner would be
how likely it is that the trait would be
accepted
and then finally the rate of cultural
evolution under these different modes of
transmission
so
actually it was this paper that led
aoki and wakano and
laurel fogarty my current postdoc to
do
a kind of simulation an agent-based
simulation of the infinitely many sites
model
and i'll tell you more details about
the comparison between
doing an analytical model of the
infinitely many sites model
and an agent-based simulation of the
infinitely many sites model which can't
be infinitely many sites
so
in the analytical model we assume that
there are infinitely many sites
mutations only occur at monomorphic
sites mutation occurs in newborns
in the simulation we assumed that the
innervation which is the analog to
mutation occurred in adults
all the traits are neutral
so there is no selection in this
however the big difference is in our
simulation there's only a finite number
of sites that are subject to the
mutation
and sometimes we inadvertently call it
the infinitely many sites model because
the kind of assumption on those finite
sites is exactly the assumption that is
made in the infinitely many sites model
of dna
evolution
our parameters
are
natural parameters the population size
and we introduce this k which is the
number of acquaintances that you meet
that will be
involved in the cultural transmission
process
this is the mutation rate or innovation
rate
and here is whether
these traits are going to be learned
perfectly if beta is one then it's the
you don't need to have any thoughts
about cultural transmission other than
the people or individuals to whom the
transmission is occurring
and finally
this is the number of traits we're going
to deal with m we call it the
imagination space
and that is the length of the vector
that would normally be all of the dna
bases
but it's not going to be that big
so you have n individuals and at each
time step one individual is born
the newborn acquires a variant of each
trait from older individuals by social
learning
and then one of the random older
individuals is chosen to die
and this is exactly the moran model of
reproduction in a cultural context
a very famous model widely used in
population genetics
so the life expectancy of that newborn
is actually end time steps in the scale
of the births and deaths that occur in
the moran model
so this is a classical picture of the uh
rate of evolution
a mutation or innervation occurs and
most of the time it'll disappear by
drift and occasionally it'll go to
fixation
and the average uh
rate
is this
one over this space
between in time between those uh
fixation states and that's the analog of
the rate of cultural evolution that
we're going to use
and this is due to
kimura
that
the rate of evolution is the population
size times the mutation rate times the
probability that a mutation
arising once in the population fixes
is a classical formula from kimura
so
we can
look at it in a very simplistic way put
time this way and frequency this way the
mutations are going along up there this
is where fixation occurs
and we'll so in this particular case
three fixations occurred
and the time between successive
fixations
was t1 t2 and t3
and
the r is the total number of
uh fixations in the denominator and the
um
a time total on the top
so you take this invert it and you get
the classical rate of fixation
now here's a trivial example where the
imagination space is four
every individual is defined as a four
vector
in this agent-based simulation
this particular one at trait one has a
zero we're only going to deal with
dichotomous traits that are only going
to be zeros and ones
so each individual might innervate
they're only going to
innovate in the beginning at monomorphic
sites
later we'll allow recurrent mutation to
happen
and
that will change the way in which the
evolution occurs because in the
infinitely many sites model this doesn't
is not allowed
so
there's a particular population five
individuals each with their own
vector of cultural traits
and
we're going to do different modes of
learning
there are four main ones that we
consider random oblique learning is
completely analogous to
the watterson model of transmission of
just one mutation and you copy
that individual and go on into the next
generation and then and then a random
individual dies this is completely
analogous to the classical moran model
these are not
these are totally different
this one
two individuals or k individuals are
chosen
and you look at some properties of those
individuals and copy those
before you make it into the next
generation and a random individual is
killed
that's a
variant of the moran model with cultural
transmission based on your learning from
k individuals
success
bias is where you copy all of the
individuals who've got a one you copy
the ones into those positions in you and
you go into the next generation
and one-to-many transmission is where
one individual is chosen and that
individual is regarded as a teacher for
all the other individuals and its traits
are transmitted
to all the other sampled individuals
until it dies and then another
individual is randomly chosen to be the
teacher
so these variants of the moran model all
are expected to produce different
results
and they do
so here's the random oblique model going
into action the newborn is always all
zeros
this particular one is gonna
copy this guy and becomes this
and this individual is chosen to die
and is replaced by that individual so
that's the moran model uh as watterson
would have done it
um
this is the success bias model you copy
the individual with the most ones so
this is the newborn
this guy has three ones
we're only he randomly chose he could
have chosen this one too because that
one's got three ones
and
each
we randomly chose those three
individuals to be the ones among whom
he's gonna copy
so he will copy this individual
and
in the best of k model
you
choose ones from
k individuals here and you copy the ones
from those positions that have ones
so this particular individual has a one
here and a one here
and if you go through it you can change
the classical moran
dynamics the markov chain which
describes the
transitions from one time step to
another and then you do n of those time
steps to get a complete generation and
this is the probability that you adopt
one the probability of adopting zero
this is the death probability and the
birth probability this is the classical
thing that is in uh textbooks on uh
population genetics so this this markov
chain describes what's going on in the
random oblique model
and you can do analogous things for all
of the models except the success bias
model we haven't figured out how you
would write out the mathematics for that
so in the best of k for example this
tells you what the fixation probability
is
if you
start from uh one individual then you've
got to compute things that go through
this markov chain you end up with
fixation probabilities which are
classical these things are now
part of the
corpus of population genetic theory the
difference is that it's best of k so
everything depends on k and population
genetic theory you don't have that k
there
and this is the difference in the
cultural evolutionary rate
and it depends very much on k when you
shift from having copied one individual
or copied to individual you have a big
shift in the cultural evolutionary rate
this is a bit unexpected and what's
unexpected about it is that when you go
up from two to three you don't get such
a change in the cultural evolutionary
rate and it gets even smaller as you
increase the number of individuals that
you copy it's a very big step from one
to two and not from then on
um that we don't we don't fully
understand why that is yet but it's a
fact that these are the analytical
results for the infinitely many sites
model with the population size
going up to 250
and
you can ask do the simulations agree
with the analytical model remembering
that the simulations don't have into
infinitely many sites
so
let's take 170 long vector for each
individual
and we'll iterate for 1500 generations
and there'll be one mutation per
individual per generation
and
these are the simulation results
with a small population size going up to
and we put these three models in this
picture and the best of k in this
picture
these are the simulation these are the
exact analytical results
the ones with circles
and
we don't have results that are
analytical for this
so what we see is the analytical and
simulation results for 170 traits are
identical
for a population size up to 25.
now watterson in 1975
presented with a beautiful paper on the
expected number of segregating sites in
the population
and the variance in the number of
segregating sites in the population
and so we decided to see
how well
with the infinitely many sites model the
statistics given by watterson match the
statistics given by us
and uh
in this particular uh
example for instance there are three
traits in the population although these
are not considered as traits yet until
they've been innovated
so when there's a learning probability
that's better less than one
then the number of segregating traits or
the number of traits is exactly the same
thing you don't have to worry about that
difference
this is the comparison between the
results of watterson 1975
for infinitely many sites using exactly
the same mutation rate
exactly the same population size
and this is our simulation results
with
500 simulations
a 200 length vector of sites
and the random oblique model and you can
see that we're very close
that with 200 sites we're almost at the
infinitely many sites model
um
so
the
take home message here is that with
about 200 sites or an agent based
simulation with these kinds of cultural
transmission systems is com completely
uh do it first doable but second
that uh the results are likely to be
very informative in comparison to the
standard model
and the standard model would be the
random oblique model and against that
model which is the same as watterson's
model we can make all our comparisons
and that's what the project is that
we're working on now is actually go
through and make those comparisons to
see just exactly how sensitive it is to
the
number of traits in the vector of traits
to the population size to whether you
learn with that parameter better or not
and it's actually turning out to be a
very rich class of agent-based
simulations
thank you
yeah just one minute i want to put up
who the collaborators are
and then i just wanted to hear some sort
of example of going
yeah well there's been a couple that
we've
published
relatively recently
and one of them has has to do with
uh the context of education
and we divided education into educated
and uneducated as one of the traits
and the other trait was attitudes toward
this is females
the attitudes towards fertility control
so if the first is like an institution
uh the second is a trait that you're
going to keep track of
and the transmission of the attitudes
towards fertility control
depend on the level of education of the
individual you're dealing with and the
frequency of that level of education in
the population
so we applied that one
the example i gave of religion and uh
attitudes towards contraception is also
another example that was in the paper we
had in uh preceding the royal society so
we we keep looking for examples like
that where
there is a good enough basis for
assuming that there is some kind of a
cultural niche that is uh defining what
will be the transmission rates of some
other cultural trait that you're
interested in and they're not that much
data out there and that's because
anthropologists don't think in terms of
collecting data in that form
and it would be a big help if they did
to test for yeah
of the traits
because many of these things
yeah
okay how would we do it if we were
geneticists
we'd actually compute linkage this
equilibrium
and that's what we do here too when in
the multi-dimensional traits we keep
track of all of the statistical
associations between the different
traits
and that is some evidence for
uh association in transmission
but it could be association in fitness
it could be association in homophily
as well so um got to be a bit careful
but we do keep track of the
disequilibrium
yeah i'm just wondering what traits are
the sort of the first ones that come to
mind on me i'm sitting there thinking of
vocabulary ah
don't mention any particular traits
yeah
one of the
things that we're
actually working on
heavily now is the presence and absence
of phonemes in a language
so it's not looking in that case at
individuals within a group it's looking
at the evolution of the language as a
whole
and so we have a database which can the
two databases one of them consist of 700
phonemes presence or absence
000 languages
and we're in the process of trying to
simulate the geography of that process
to see whether
it matches what we know about the uh
serial founder effect in genes out of
africa
the data that we have on that
seems to
be weekly in agreement with the serial
founder effect that there's a slight
regression
that shows a decrease in variability
from africa to the americas
but it's not nearly as strong as
atkinson proposed he was using
about a third of the number of phonemes
didn't have as many languages and the
statistics that he did are a little uh
strange
it turns out that the main determinant
of
these of the that phonemic variability
is whether you include clicks or not
and
the
south african
variety of clicks
turns out to determine where the best
origin
for
in the world for phonemic variation is
if you leave phonemes out
altogether that have clicks in them the
best origin is in europe
which is really weird
but there are so many cliques in this uh
southern part of africa that it makes it
makes a very big difference
so that that's uh
one of the uh best examples that we're
dealing with at the moment
absolutely analysis are you finding
evidence because in the
theoretical analysis mutation is a big
part of the story
i'm just wondering in the analysis that
you see
languages
it's easier to do it with cognates than
it is with phonemes
but what we do see is an effect of this
best of k
that
those languages
that have the most
neighbors that have different phonemic
ranges from themselves
are the ones that uh change the fastest
so there's a kind of an um neighborhood
effect
that we that hasn't been identified in
the literature before